[Applause]
oh I can feel it in the air tonight I
know cuz it's Super Bowl weekend ladies
and gentlemen you must be excited about
the Super Bowl it's our national
religion football come on you love the
Super Bowl you [ __ ] come on the Super
Bowl they don't care in LA in America I
know you care
come on Super Bowl the one Sunday when
American men can drink openly in the
house and not secretly in the garage you
gotta love it I am so looking for it not
just of the game I'm really looking
forward to the Katy Perry halftime show
the the NFL and Commissioner Roger
Goodell assured everyone today no funny
business her tits will be fully inflated
that we know deflation dictate their and
in honor of her fabulous tits they are
also at halftime
going to retired Janet Jackson's nipple
which i think is fantastic we all
remember from 10 years ago to that time
now the anticipation for this game is at
a fever pitch everybody wants to know
how will the Patriots cheat this week I
kid the Patriots I could give a [ __ ] but
they are cheaters
and winners they're great too who knows
what happens okay but they got out of
town just in time to get to the super
would you see that because the blizzard
of 2015 anybody get caught in that whoo
rough stuff back east especially in the
Boston area New York kind of escaped
although they say in New York the
conditions are still dangerously icy and
that's just between the cops and the
mayor so you know speaking of I see big
political news today Mitt Romney out run
again he said it today I'm not gonna do
it
he wanted to run but it's a health issue
his doctors talked to met the stress
from pretending to care about poor
people could kill him so he but what a
hole he leaves in the Republican Party
what where are they gonna find another
bland soulless white guy I mean
it's tough well President Obama had a
busy week overseas he was in India and
gave a speech over there
urging them to be more progressive about
women's rights and then he went to Saudi
Arabia where they keep women and
beekeeper suits
I didn't say a word oh is there anything
you can't do
he didn't say a word but Michelle Obama
I love her man she went over there and
she did not wear the headscarf did not
cover her head you go girl
many Saudi citizens complained about it
on Twitter it was all over their
favorite social media site cover your
Facebook well let's let's be respectful
to other cultures please and Saudi
Arabia it is in considered indecent for
a woman to show or uncovered head unless
it's separated from her body then it's
perfectly fine excuse me but the new
king he's been there about three days
he's already beheaded four people
stability that's what we look for in
Saudi Arabia continuity and stability
and we have it they continued the
beheadings speaking of beheadings Isis
is threatening to behead a Japanese
hostage if they don't trade a woman
suicide bomber a member of I know this
is true there's a woman suicide bomber
member of Isis who has been captured and
they want her back she went on a suicide
bombing mission with her husband they
were both going to blow themselves up
but his bomb went off and hers didn't
oldest trick in the book it's it's
called 51 ways to leave your lover okay
and Isis also released another video
this weekend threatened Obama they said
no Obama that we will cut your head off
in the White House in the White House
dream on [ __ ] first of all you'd
have to get over the fit